hi it's benito skinner aka benny drama
and today i'm christening the digital
hub at the drew barrymore show i've got
something in store for drew that i think
she's gonna love
because what's better than one drew
two dribs
let's do this
double double toil and trouble
so good
yes
let's do this
oh my god it's like multiplicity i know
look
look at this
okay wait sit down yes oh my god of
course um
so
as much as i love the idea of there
being two of us two of us twins
i have to say that i would love if i
could ask benny a question oh my god
okay i think he's in here somewhere yes
yes
knock knock i'm just like uh sorry
method
not today drew
um wow okay yes i'd be honored benny
would you come out yeah
yeah hi drew i'm here i want to ask you
some questions yeah because i think that
you have
really truly changed the game and you
might have some real pearls of wisdom
for people who
want to find their voice
in this world what is your process how
do you
come up out of thin air in the ether
with your characters so sometimes it'll
be like i'll get a line stuck in my head
or something that i think is funny like
when i did
uh jonathan van ness as jesus
i could be hearing them say like okay
judas road and it just like kept go so
something like that where i'm like i
almost like build a video around that
yeah then sometimes it's just kind of
like a life experience like i got my
hair cut one time from this girl who
just like made me feel so safe but was
definitely telling me too much like
about her life
and it just after a few haircuts they
were like that was like this character
of jenny came to be and then i was like
she would also work at mac like this
girl is like she's hair and makeup
she's like she's got multiple jobs when
you write stuff in your notes app do you
like go back and revisit it yeah or does
it like kind of fall in the dump well
sometimes i think a really good idea
will come up multiple times
and then also a really good idea you
won't see so like if i see someone do
something like similar or if i feel like
the video i'm doing isn't like
a fresh take or something like that i'm
like okay i don't think i need to spend
hours editing that you know i want to do
something i'm excited about that feels
fresh and new i think a good example is
like i saw
a fellow comedian of mine um makes
dalter she did like a barbie video and
i'd always had this idea of maybe doing
barbie and then like ken and and so
instead i was just like wait let's make
it together you're barbie and i'll be
ken and then sometimes it'll just be
like it's time some things i can do fast
which is nice like
you know the kourtney kardashian travis
barker relationship i saw that kind of
spring up and i was like oh well i have
to act now how do you think like because
comedy can be funny at other people's
expenses yeah and somehow you go all the
way with it and it's as charming and
like i feel like the kardashians love
you they've been very sweet i mean i
always
for me to do what i do
and do an impression or something it
just i have to be invested in the person
and love them so i've never done a video
on something that i didn't care about
like everything i've done i think it's
it's really
more of an homage because i'm like i
love it and i
i think this thing is funny about it and
i
i really want people to feel like
they're in on the joke with me i think
people you know who i've made videos of
they feel the love um because it is
there i really i i don't i never
want to be an internet bully or so like
that was never my goal it is
so loving what you do
it doesn't compromise on the funny how
did you prep as they say to be to be you
i oh my god okay i think just it's it
goes back to me only doing like
impressions of like something i consume
a lot of
so i mean i've seen
everything you've made and i think i you
know i watch your show i want like i
follow you on instagram so it's like
i've studied you so much but it just i
like i don't know i i think since i was
a kid i just like love picking up on
you know the nuances of of what someone
does so i think you're walking a
tightrope that's very difficult for
people to create and stay on and you're
doing like the best job with it thank
you it's true
we are all so similar we've seen you
know so many of the same things and i
feel like you know i'm fortunate i have
a collaborator who's you know also my
boyfriend and my partner so it's like if
he also feels it that's i almost like
tests sometimes where i'm like wait can
you watch this really quick and no
matter what he'll also be like oh not
that one yeah in fact i'll end the
conversation with this note and i think
it's so true for this conversation is my
friend elisa texted me
um the other day and she's like
what do you think like should i do this
or say this and i said i think if you're
questioning it you have your answer yeah
it's not worth it trust that weird
little sensation that has doubt and
um uncertainty yeah like don't risk it
yeah
um that said you take so many risks and
yet just you just don't step in it and
it's such a beautiful thing to see i
think everybody's ideal dream
relationship um or a lot of people's
ideal dream relationship is to be
believed in to be supported and to
actually have someone like collaborate
with you how sexy and fun yeah i'm
literally crying i'm so sorry barbara
walters charlie switched it off i just
have this where i'm like oh my god i'm
literally sitting with drew barrymore i
mean it's just i i feel so lucky to do
what i do you are pioneering something
and this will get traced back to you and
it's just so wonderful because it is
hard
to come up with something new yeah in
this world and you're doing it and so
are you
we're so lucky to have you oh thank you
[Music]